what do you think that maybe they hired
Donald Trump because they knew there
were so many Republicans that are
[ __ ] they could just get him to the
podium and then he would crumble under
the weight of Hillary Clinton it's the
greatest professional wrestling act ever
ever really is it's crazy hair
could you imagine giving that dude a pot
cookie and a mirror and go hey bro
what's going on up here what is this
what's going on what are you doing this
is this is madness if you have you know
you just go like short trimmed hair with
some bald spots like it's just that's
way more gangster than what you're doing
like what you're doing is kind of crazy
the hair does not look like that it just
doesn't look like that ever in the wild
just like what you've done is you've
used some sort of chemicals to concoct
some things and his face is it really
that is that the lighting orange is
really that red and orange they do him
up but the kind of people that do him up
are probably like the kind of people
that really like him and they kind of
like some orange skin they want to fight
both of them it's more paint they want
to fight why doesn't he do the under
eyes like if you're gonna do your whole
your face like that do you think he
wears like giant goggles when he gets in
the tanning booth is that what's going
on like why is this just rice eyes just
white surely he knows what he looks like
right but dad needs to but then you look
at his hair and you go well why is he
doing that then
[Music]